foreign
let's go to Rebecca in Medford Oregon
what's up Medford uh not Medford what's
up Rebecca how we doing
hi Dr John thank you for taking my call
of course really big fan I really
appreciate it thank you so much I'm
grateful for you what's up
um I'm just wondering
um I found out some very shocking things
10 months ago I found it out all in one
day
um my question is how can I heal after
finding out my husband has been keeping
secrets for me throughout our entire
28-year marriage what kind of Secrets
I just had a
[Music]
um but I had a a weird feeling
um and I checked his computer
and what I found out was completely
overwhelming
um he had reached out to an
ex-girlfriend
um two years prior
um nothing came of it but he had reached
out
um I found out he had a porn addiction
um lots and lots of porn it seemed to
have
it escalated it looked like into some
Kinks I had no idea
that he was into he was reaching out to
couples
um
he was in chat rooms the way that he was
speaking to other people was definitely
not the person I knew were very close
we've been best friends for so long we
just you know we're very close we have
each other's backs I know him inside and
out and I feel like he knows me except I
have never once lied to him the way he
he was speaking to these people
um was crass graphic
but the most disturbing to me is that he
had showed
to these random online people's photos
of me
sexualizing me describing my
measurements
um and a desire of me to be with another
man in front of him
they weren't nude photos of me but they
were racy photos you know just shorts um
and like a low-cut tank top that you
know I just would never ever in a
million years think that he would share
that with someone
um and all these things I found out
were were so shocking um and I just
found out more and more stuff as I as I
read through I started crying
um I felt like I had been kicked in the
stomach and everything I knew about him
was it just switched in a moment's time
um I I I just I had no idea he felt this
way or that he was even capable of doing
something like this
so this was 10 months ago
um yeah tell me about the last 10 months
how's that going
um well I I kicked him out we have a a
trailer so I kicked him out um to get
some space I was Furious uh I couldn't
stand to even look at him how did he
take that did he say I understand or did
he goes no it first he um gaslit me and
made excuse is until
as when I approached him I gave him a
chance to be honest on his own and he
was not and it wasn't until I presented
him with black and you know there in
black and white what I read and he could
not deny it anymore and then he became
no he left willingly
um he let me kick and scream he took it
and then he was just he wrote me a
letter after letter after letter while
he was gone just he's in deep shame
I'm extremely remorseful crying
um it's been a rough 10 months very up
and down
and he I mean he went so far as he made
a list of everything he was going to do
to get better
and has followed through with most of it
um he may you know he became very
transparent
um he put
um you know locks on anything porn
related
um he just quit overnight it seemed just
overnight and all of that I appreciate
he's been trying very very hard he did
promise to go to counseling and get us
in marriage counseling if I would agree
and that has not happened
um we've actually been for 10 months
he's been fighting with the insurance
company and not getting a response yeah
I don't care I don't care about that
um yeah uh so how can I help you so it's
like just though the whole world blew up
um it blew up I didn't know how we would
go on right
um I I felt trapped sure
I feel absolutely trapped overwhelmed
and we had just moved out of state and I
thought I would I told him I would have
never made this move with you if I had
known this was going on the hardest part
for me now yeah how can I how can I help
you yeah from just my point of view is
that I feel I don't trust myself I don't
trust him I don't trust any other men so
I feel helpless in that
I feel disoriented
and the anger like I do I do really well
we do we do fine and then all of a
sudden the anger will pop up and it
keeps popping up and I know I want to
heal from this I want to get better
it it's gonna take a long time
[Music]
11 months four days three hours
um so good I got my calendar yeah it'll
it'll just clean right up right there
um yeah okay couple of things I it's
very very rare
that this doesn't happen
that
he hasn't come fully clean
so that's number one yep okay yep
um number two
it's very rare that this happens that
somebody says I was completely blown
away caught off guard
that remember that movie The Sixth Sense
with Bruce Willis and remember the end
of that movie and you're like oh no and
they actually do a really amazing job of
showing you all the places where you
missed it
yes and it's easy to look back on your
life and go uh oh no oh no right and
that's that sense of
I think I knew this all along or parts
of this or not all of it but oh my gosh
this makes sense and then I remember
this conversation I remember this
question and then that's that feeling
you get which is most people don't
realize that when somebody's cheating on
you
are Unfaithful in any number of ways oh
yeah the most disorienting thing is you
don't trust yourself anymore like man
how did I miss all of this right yeah um
I also think that this is a little
unique situation and here's why
um
it feels like you don't know this guy
and you can't trust this guy and
everything about him is a lie that's not
true
he is the guy that sat with you and I'm
just gonna make up some stuff I don't
know if any of this is true but he is
the guy that sat with you and your mom
got sick he was the guy that showed up
on Christmas morning like those things
happened and those are real and you
can't throw all of that out that
happened
okay okay
um and it's real easy to be like none of
this is real none of this is true that's
that's a defense mechanism it is the
harder part is dealing with the Paradox
of you sat with me and held my hand
while my dad passed away and then you
went home and got on our computer
and that that's a harder thing to deal
with than just swinging that thing my
husband's perfect my husband's the devil
it's always in the middle always in the
middle okay
here's where I think this is a little
bit unique
um and I hope I say this the right way
in a way that comes across that makes
sense
you clearly violated your trust and he
violated um he kept secrets from you
okay yeah when it comes to things I'm
interested in or it comes into a fantasy
world
um that's not uncommon okay it's
heartbreaking and it makes people sad
but it's not uncommon
okay where he crossed a line for me
is he took pictures of you and put them
out to the world
he brought you into a situation
that
um in a way that is for me personally is
above and beyond a normal guy got
started looking at pornography and kind
of got sucked on a rabbit hole and ended
up you know in some chat rooms and just
it becomes Dungeons and Dragons a
pornographic Dungeons and Dragons right
it's a fantasy world so super separate
from The Real World okay that is crazy
as it sounds that that doesn't bother me
that is I mean it bothers me in the
clearly hurting people it's not weird or
crazy okay yeah what's weird and crazy
is taking pictures of your wife and
putting them on the Internet and saying
hey any any Seekers here's her
measurements that to me is such another
layer of a violation here that
um I I have a hard time coming back from
that to be honest with you because yeah
he's uh he dragged you into something
that you don't even know you're being
dragged into
no idea right and so I want to validate
your I want this to work but I can't
seem to make it
right like you're hurt and violation is
very very very real above and beyond
what I would call and I hate to use this
word it's just the world I'm in a normal
um
pornography addiction or a normal
um uh violation like someone's someone
is you know spending time erotic time in
a fantasy world this is above and beyond
so
the question you have to ask yourself is
are you playing house
are you playing Mary just on your terms
meaning you kicked him out but I still
go to dinner with him we've still been
intimate we're still friends we're still
hanging out all the time
but then I just get raged out and what
you're doing is you're
you're trying to heal a wound but you
keep pulling the Band-Aid off
yeah
is that fair yes yes okay absolutely
you've got and it and I hate to bring
his feelings into this but they are a
part of it because y'all been married a
long time and his feelings are a part of
you whether you want them to be or not
um it can be cruel too as it could be it
could be well it's a form of punishment
I'm gonna punish you through this right
yeah and that doesn't help anybody do
anything that's that's a that's a waste
of energy and time what you have to
decide is what do I need right now and
I'm telling you just as your friend if
you need I need to cut off contact with
you for a season
feel fully empowered and no it is Hell
on the other side of that
yeah it's lonely it's sad it's
heartbreaking and that doesn't mean it's
the wrong thing
okay okay and yeah if everybody's
telling you you just leave him you
forget this guy's a bum whoever and you
say this is my husband and we're gonna
figure this out I said till death do us
part come what may I'm here
um that's gonna be a bumpy ride too and
so maybe the best gift I could give you
is there is no smooth ride out of this
the hard part is nobody knows
you know that's right I have
I haven't needed to talk to you to even
say it out loud because nobody knows
they think he's perfect
and so you've heard me say this from the
great David Kessler grief demands a
witness
and what's hot what your what you're
experiencing right now that anger that
Rage that's grief
yeah that is we set this sucker up dude
and you blew it up
yeah right it feels like grief it is
that's exactly what it is you are
mourning the death of what was
and now what you get to choose is what
is going to be and if we if you choose
for what is going to be with him great
y'all gonna have to work really hard
and you're gonna have to get a new
architect to help you draw a new
building and you're gonna have to get
new contractors to help you build
something totally new because what you
had is over it's gone it is yeah and if
you choose I'm moving into a duplex um I
don't want another big building that's
another Avenue for you as well
um but I haven't seen that very
successful
mm-hmm
without some space
okay
and I have never seen somebody do this
successfully by themselves about without
telling people out loud
they're going to be
um
you know I mean you can probably guess
my fear in that is that I don't want
people to judge my husband
um
yeah
isolated I feel so isolated right
and you are continuing to prop up the
image of this perfect little family that
you had
you have to let that go because it's not
real
yeah you're right you're right and maybe
the first step is calling a close friend
and letting them letting her know I'm
about to blow your mind
they they will fall down in shock it I
mean I I can you know I
they will go through a fraction of what
I went through when I found out because
I why are you protecting them why are
you protecting him
I'll tell you why you've been protecting
him your whole marriage
yeah oh I have yeah I know you're all
married you've been protecting him at
some point Rebecca you have to decide
that you're worth being well and you're
worth being whole
even if that means what what you the
fantasy land you've kept duct tape
together for 20 or 30 years is no more
yes
or when they say what if they say things
back that actually hurt me they will
they will say stupid things like well
what did you do is it such a big deal
like you'll get all that stuff right and
really quickly you will be able to
determine how close these friends
actually are
but let me tell you the word like the
word that we're dancing around here that
I hate more than anything is
vulnerability
you only way forward to heal
is to vulnerability literally means to
roll over and expose your belly so that
another animal can come kill you and
hoping that they choose not to
and that's what it feels like right oh
that's fear yeah oh my gosh so let me be
very clear your friends could roast you
they could destroy you
mm-hmm
they can
yeah but if you don't find people to
talk to this will you will be the
casualty here
ah yeah it's so isolating I feel
disorder I feel disoriented it is and
when you start saying these things out
loud and seeing the shock on their face
you're going to get a new perspective of
what you're experiencing so before the
day is over your homework assignment is
to call two friends
and invite them over
and tell them everything
all of it
everything even the stuff you left out
which I guarantee you left stuff out of
this call
and maybe open up to your friends and
say I ain't gonna I'm gonna need help
practicing not protecting him
anymore
I'm gonna need help wading through all
this grief all this shame all of this I
should have said something a long long
time ago I've had these feelings in my
guts for years and I just ignored them
you're gonna need help practicing
trusting Rebecca again
and in many ways it's gonna feel like
you're going to rehab and learn how to
walk
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
I'll be here with you every step of the
way call anytime email anytime and I'd
love to have you back on the show and we
can figure this thing out together as we
go but you gotta have two people that
you called today invite them over in
person tonight and have that
conversation that is uncomfortable as
it's gonna be is where the healing will
begin